what the hell were you doing you're 3
hours late dad you don't understand the
car was busted so we had to shred why
your lips red were you eating a snow
cone it's a really good guess what kind
of adults roller blade the police are
here and they're saying that you bought
alcohol for miners thanks Boys in Europe
the drinking age is like 10 they could
have been European what made you think
they were European they had a certain
Gena qua I think one of them was eating
pant on
shakala guys everyone thinks we're
losers but that's about to
change I know where The Treasure of
Foggy Mountain is from when we were kids
we are looking at 100 Mil $100 million
it'd be like I mean I know it's more
than this but at least a million each
significantly more what are we waiting
for the cute guys that came in earlier I
didn't see nobody cute the ginger look
like a colonial ghost glasses look like
Tim Burton Drew him and in a short one
we probably were a same size bra they
had a treasure map with like an x on it
we going to steal that
map that is a fullon hawk hey buddy trse
it
theck does it not know it can fly why
did it walk away with an attitude
everyone is after this
treasure we deserve that you deserve it
yeah three white guys whose biggest
issue is what growing up no it's more
nuanced than
that you just hit a woman apologize for
him I for one would
never oh my God so I've one woman that's
not in the
grand welcome new friends we can all
agree this is a scary cult and we're
waiting for the other shoe to drop we're
in a docy series and this is episode two
dude
completely insane night guys why are we
tied
up I'd rather die than live without you
boys oh
guys look dude that's that's the
treasure door open
it what that I would be sick I would be
sick to my stomach forget the money it's
not worth
it